lunch money time well while she's trying
to get rich the rest of us just trying
to get her lunch money right clinton how
are you i'm great do i look like a
farmer or like a painter today a painter
and you also have on a sailor shirt like
you're sailing
no yes okay hey sherwin williams go
ahead
not sure when all right let's go sherwin
for real okay
inflation
do i need to say more barreled ahead at
8.3 percent in april from a year ago
remaining near 40-year highs
well technically it didn't barrel ahead
so whoever wrote that article well
whoever wrote that article jeff cox
cnbc jeff cox at cnbc who's fantastic
well he wrote the article i'm just
saying he probably is miss uh uh uh you
could say it a different way instead of
saying barrel of the head instead it
went from 8.5 it dropped to 8.3 percent
now why it dropped we'll talk about in a
second but it's important to understand
where this is coming from
gasoline is up 43 over the last 12
months food
at home is up 10.8
that is completely unsustainable for the
average american family if you look at
food outside of the home it's up 7.2
percent if you look at shelter it's
supposedly up 5
new cars up 13
now none of this matters literally the
number does not matter anymore you know
why because they messing with the number
so let me explain three things that are
going on right now the first thing is
they randomly came out and said oh we're
switching up the calculation for new
cars in the cpi
what do you mean how are you
manipulating the economic data and the
calculations in the middle of the
highest inflation in 40 years
i don't think they're doing that because
they think that the number is going to
become more accurate they're probably
doing it because i think the number will
go down which will make the overall
basket seem cheaper and therefore you
get 8.3
the second thing is that there's article
after article after article that
explains
how
national rents up about 20
real estate prices up about 20
if the national rent and real estate is
up about 20
how is it that the bureau of labor
statistics reports
that the
shelter is only a 5 percent i'm not
einstein but if everything's up twenty
percent you can't then say five percent
it's under counting everything this is
eight point three percent number wrong
it's definitely in the teens the
question is just how bad is it and so
when you look at they're manipulating
the data they're manipulating the
calculations and they also are just
pulling numbers out of their ass
essentially you can say to yourself
inflation is bad and at this point the
difference between 8.5 8.3
doesn't really matter so going back to
our boy jeff cox i actually would argue
that although it went down his sentiment
of it's just continuing to persist
actually i would agree with that part of
it and so what you have to remember is
it did go down but what we are seeing
here is double digit real inflation the
average american is absolutely getting
crushed
and yesterday joe biden gave a speech
and it sounded literally it was like
south park did it he literally got up
there and he said this is my number one
domestic priority
and the way that we're gonna solve this
i swear to god what i'm about to say
this is what he said
he's going to ask corporations not to
price gouge
inflation is a 40-year high and we're
gonna just like say mr corporation will
you please not price gouge that's insane
then as if that's not bad enough on top
of it he said oh we're also going to tax
corporations and the wealthiest
americans
let me bring you guys back to economics
101. if i increase your cost
taxes
then what are you going to do you're
going to increase your prices if you
increase your prices that means the
person on the other end who's buying
your goods is going to pay a higher
price if they pay a higher price that
leads to inflation
so by taxing people more or taxing
corporations more you actually continue
to perpetuate the problem
this is classic
socialism is stupid
and capitalism works
get out of the market as a politician
and a central bank
and let the market work because you know
what's going to happen it's going to be
bad
it's going to be bad as they intervene
but if you don't actually do anything
it's going to come down naturally you
know why it's going to come down
naturally but isn't that why they
intervene because it's going to be
terrifying if
they just don't do anything
we would not have 8.5 inflation in the
official numbers if they never
intervened in 2020
they created the problem so have you
ever heard of central bankers they're
firefighters who or their arsonist
that start a fire and then show up and
pretend to be firefighters
that's that's all they are they they
created this problem and now we're like
oh please save us please save us they're
not saving us
if you've been watching lunch money
since 2020 you'll remember when we
talked about how like a lot of the
things that they were doing were
short-term solutions that in the long
term would be painful i cannot can i pat
ourselves on the back what we nailed
this one y'all can go back check the
receipts all the way from 2020 we called
this out over and over and over and over
again the one thing that i was wrong on
that he was right on was uh what's his
name
andrew andrew cuomo yeah the real ones
remember the real ones remember i was
like he is not going to be criminally
charged are you crazy and then you all
thought i was crazy when i said this
dude definitely getting in trouble
probably
and he did criminally and everyone's
like what do you mean there's no way i
said this dude is not a good dude i
caught
sniffed out that one real quick just in
defense of my
fellow
friend i guess uh jeff cox he's actually
a fan he's probably one of my favorite
books this is what i want to say
inflation did barrow ahead at 8.3 in
april from a year ago it says to be
awesome kind of giving him a hard time
just because barrel ahead is such a uh
such a great headline and
by the way reporters typically don't
write the headlines so fyi
um it's probably written by somebody
else
netflix
could launch streaming with ads
even sooner than we expected do you
think this is a good idea
i mean
from what sense is a viewer or if i was
working in that well let me rewrite the
headline netflix invents
television
no netflix sells out
to
pay its bills
no but they i mean that's what tv is
right you're watching a stream and then
they just put ads in the middle
yeah but you can't do it like
television's like live
yeah but they but there's plenty of
recorded content you love friends yeah
and friends is no different than a tv
show it docks me over here okay like an
episodic show on netflix but then they
just put ads in between no i get it but
on tv you have to wait till 8 pm on tbs
to watch friends yeah a scheduled
viewing viewing now let me ask you this
do you think that the ads will be you
get a free account you can watch netflix
for free with ads or do you think that
they're going to absolutely nuke their
membership base and say even though
you're paying us for a membership we're
also going to throw ads in on top oh
that's a good question i don't know
there'll be a revolt in the streets
netflix will just create a death spiral
of unsubscribes if i pay you
to watch netflix and then you hit me
with the ads i don't know you're gonna
lose me dawg i mean
they already been ratcheting up the
price yeah that's what i was gonna say
netflix has been doing whatever it takes
to pay its bills and i feel like this is
just how much is netflix how much does
netflix go for 19.99 in an incognito
window check to see how much a netflix
subscription is i started out i was like
nine i was what is it 1999. i was at
9.99
price hikes over the years let's see
see she's trying to do all those okay
from 2014 it started at 7.99
and yeah i got in at 9.99 and then today
i think it's uh it's 19.99 i believe
yeah it's 19.99 am i grandfathered in or
am i paying 20 bucks i think you're
paying 20 bucks
that that's a tax
that sucks
okay next ready let's do it so twitter
is already implementing new things to
combat spam and duplicative tweets you
know who else needs to do this youtube
do you see the comments on youtube i am
like
how many fake anthony's are there i
can't even tell them apart anymore i
don't know who you are that's fine i'm
cool with them whatever what uh twitter
you know what twitter's doing right now
if you said that twitter
you you just went from like uh
uh taking a nap to oh [ __ ] i'm
productive as hell elon don't fire me
elon don't fire me elon don't hell yeah
elon is about to fire half the team you
think he's gonna clean house you know
why no because the team that's there
they ain't the team that's gonna get
them where they need to go you know why
because if that team was gonna do it
they would have already done it that
team has gotten them here no it hasn't
twitter basically has gone sideways from
a stock price standpoint for the last
seven years or whatever it is like since
2014 or something okay but let's talk
about the
uh focus on spam that's been a really
big issue you gotta fix it you he's been
tweeting at jack dming with like no i
never i never uh get jack on it yeah
because jack was worried about let's say
run two companies but i'm cool with jack
jack and i are cool he's gonna go
who are you tweeting at about the ceo
i say prague let's go buddy
he must not use twitter the ceo twitter
must not use twitter why because he
would fix the problem if he was using
twitter because it's everywhere there's
nobody on twitter that's like oh this is
good for the platform there's nobody
so literally my working theory is that
the ceo of twitter does not use twitter
yeah because if he used twitter he get
rid of the spam you know what else they
should get rid of the mean people on
twitter
they're rid of them all it literally
it probably would take like two
engineers
three days to fix this this is the
simplest so why why don't they do it
most likely because i don't know
10
20
of all their user numbers would
immediately drop
or they would drop uh 10 to 20 oh you
mean active users all that stuff because
that account counts as an active user oh
that's suspicious
i don't want to get into all the details
you all want to know y'all want to know
one of the biggest uh
connections
twitter's twitter's numbers yes are as
deceptive as the inflation numbers same
people might be running it
well what i was going to say this is why
i like you
i should keep you around uh
[Applause]
[Music]
one of the reasons why uh this is all
nonsense yeah
there's no auditing of the numbers
or the inflation the biggest issue
at these companies is a lot of their
valuation is derived by their user
numbers
all those bots
count
it's not good for the business it's not
good for investors get rid of them
yeah but then there's gonna go in there
with these flamethrowers
elon's going to go in and twitter's like
a daily active user number is going to
plummet and then the public but it's
going to be a private company it's not
going to matter
it doesn't matter
build for the long term
stop optimizing for the next quarterly
earnings report do the right thing for
the long
for the long time yeah all right next
all right
where are we let's go with your favorite
sherwin let's go
well it's true and this is my favorite
topic
so okay
so you know people like to say that the
american dream is dead
american dream whatever wrong but
but
70
sorry
so according to a new gallup
what is it called survey yeah 70 of us
adults across race gender political
party and income say the american dream
is still achievable and here's a few
stats to chew on from axios 44 of
fortune 500 companies have at least one
founder who is an immigrant or the child
of immigrants
i'm not a fortune 500 but okay um even
the children of immigrants who fall in
the poorest quarter of the u.s end up in
the middle class
and 80 percent of america's millionaires
foreign and u.s born are first
generation wow
all i have to say is that anybody who
thinks the american dream is dead
is dumb
you're dumb
because there is no better country in
the world
for anyone
in the world regardless of wealth
race religion education status who your
parents are who your friends what
language none of that stuff matters get
to the united states
and you got a shot and that's been true
for decades and it's still true today
but
it has now been outsourced
you don't actually physically have to
get to the united states true
true
we work with people all around the world
true
in various companies
some people are based in the philippines
some people are based in nigeria some
people are based in ghana some people
are based in argentina or venezuela or
canada or spain or russia or ukraine or
saudi arabia et cetera anywhere in the
world you got an internet connection
you're in the game let's go american
dream now is at your front door
since
yes i
as a child moved to the united states
yeah is sophia considered first
generation
oh that's good i don't know what the
definitions are because if i'm like
regular generation right no you're
you're generation zero
right
is that what it's called yeah you're
like the petri dish
i don't know people can tell me in the
chat i ask the people next okay okay
next is
um
no
what is the next topic ufos oh ufos
um are you good i can't see anything i'm
over here the blind leading the blind
the ufos where they don't have a hearing
yes the ufos are having
the ufos are having a hearing that's
interesting i think the i think the
politicians are going to have a hearing
there's going to be a house panel that
will hold the first public hearing on
ufos in decades i wonder why in decades
this is the first time in 50 years
they're doing this you believe in aliens
absolutely i think it's very
self-centered for you to think that
there is nothing else out in that
universe
other than us
that's very selfish what do you think
yeah there's definitely aliens oh okay i
don't know if we can find that that was
gonna be a jailbreaker real quick yeah
there's definitely aliens ufos also uh
unidentified flying objects of course
those exist people the ufo doesn't exist
well like that's unidentified flying
objects so you could say it's not aliens
but it's still ufo oh my god john said
the exact same thing yesterday did you
take that from him no what'd you say
exact same thing oh that's because john
don't everyone thinks that like uh uh
we're idiots over here we're smart
people
of course the ufo that's like the
whatever that's the definition what is
it i don't know what that thing is but
it's flying around like a tic tac i
don't care about the ufos i'm interested
in the aliens yeah so that's the
questions are there aliens or not oh i
think that um i forget who told me this
some people might call me oh you know
who said it bruce fenton uh
is a alien ancient alien researcher not
because i'm an actual alien bruce fenton
ancient alien researcher he hit me with
this idea of uh there's two questions
that everyone asks in their life
what happens after you die and are we
the only ones are we here alone
how about that gravity of the situation
our we here alone and what happens after
you die ask yourself that so what if
what if
we are the aliens to other aliens what
do you think they think of us
you ever seen a lizard see us
a lizard an ant any of those little
animals a might a mouse a mice a mice a
mouse a snake any of those things you
want to know what they do
oh [ __ ]
and they run because they're like the
aliens are here it's like a godzilla
type you wanna do you wanna tell them
about your dad moment no
i i don't wanna talk about the time that
i saw a lizard on the wall and i went up
to and i was like looking at it like
this and playing a little buddy and
plenty was like what are you doing i'm
looking at this little fella right here
and she was like that was the most dad
moment you know this is the dad's pose
oh it's kind of looking at it like look
at this little guy right here climbing
up this wall i was trying to figure it
out he's got a little claws
why is that the universal dad pose oh
it's a
contemplation moment oh okay listen
aristotle's what is his name aristotle
aristotle
and me
both probably stood there looking at an
animal
i
highly marcus aurelius
do you guys
do you guys oh john has a question
wait this is a great question but do you
guys think come on we got one minute
well okay i don't have an ass lunch
money time okay well what's the question
so hashtag ask hell i'm in the comments
below should we just ask john's question
it's do aliens get citizenship the great
question also do aliens have sex
what
it's a kid's show
it's a question
you got to start thinking about this
what aliens eat do they just drink
liquids or they eat solid foods are they
carnivores or herbivores or herbivores
whatever it's called but i can't
pronounce words but i got the ideas what
what are what are humans humans
carnivores omnivores omnivores whatever
same thing we we are carnivores which is
an omnivore so it's technically true uh
on top of that on top of that on top of
that uh one of the big questions about
aliens is that they show up one of the
big questions would be are they friendly
or are they aggressive they're friendly
all right ladies and gentlemen i
appreciate you guys today
plano will be back tomorrow
at 11am